hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast simplified imaging for
quantifying biological complexity of
IPSC derived cardiomyocytes and neurons
laying Giulio Rourke of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's webcast is presented by lab
roots comm the leading social media site
for science professionals and sponsored
by molecular devices molecular devices
is one of the world's leading providers
of high-performance bioanalytical
measurement systems instruments software
and reagents for life science research
pharmaceutical and biotech utak
development before we start there are a
few instructions this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the C button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits we want
to hear from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us a comment
answers are welcome to you can do this
by hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenters we are proud to
welcome Grisha chandi PhD senior product
manager at molecular devices and oksana
Steranko PhD or research scientist at
molecular devices grisha's scientific
background is in cell biology physiology
and biophysics he has used and developed
imaging techniques and technologies
throughout his career starting with his
doctoral work at UC irvine his postdoc
at UC berkeley as well as research
scientist position at stanford
university Krishna has been with
molecular devices for 10 years driving
the launches of for image express
Microsystems they include the image
Express micro confocal system meta
Express software versions 3 onwards and
most recently the launch of the image
Express
system and cell reporter Express
software Oksana is working on
development of new technologies for
imaging and high content analysis she
gained experience working on drug
discovery and drug development at
several biotech companies in the San
Francisco Bay Area the focus of Oksana's
current scientific research is on
development methods for high-throughput
in-vitro toxicity screening including 3d
models Oksana has a PhD in biochemistry
I will now turn it over to Grisha candy
for his introduction
you
the agenda is that I go to Chandi
product and applications manager itself
for cell analysis add meta devices will
host and be the Q&A moderator our launch
also introduce you to merkel devices
Ottoman imaging systems
I will then hand over the webinar to
oksana sore ankles senior research
scientist here at molecular devices who
will walk you through our new software
seller board Express with a workflow
focused on routine imaging assays and
she will demonstrate and show some data
on multi primary assays for compound
screening and toxic assessment with
those same IPSC derived cells I just
mentioned so a brief introduction to
multi devices automated imaging systems
so the idea is to take what you would do
with a commercial microscope which is
have a sample it might be a slide might
be multiple plate put on microscope take
an image try to make sense of what that
image is saying you know unbiased method
and make sense of the measurements you
making and the unfortunately with Mal
workflow the elapse hand time is
typically hours
now the idea with medical devices
products damaged Express systems is to
scale that up to be able to use multiple
slides multiple plates multi put them in
your system do the variety of assays and
in an unbiased way make those
measurements and make sense of that data
and drive that manual for from hours to
minutes multi devices has a variety of
image Express systems to handle a
variety of workflows that you might be
experiencing all the way from the
interface of microcon focal that is
optimized with 3d assays limit Express
micro 4 which is our bus system for very
high throughput assays or live cell
assays and the new image exists nano
system that uses new software that's
called cell report Express which acts on
we'll be introducing you to
and here I want to highlight the image
micro live cell assays that are
potential to do with our systems this
apoptotic inducer a say you know
multi-well plate where you're watching
these cells over time and you're not
staying in one well you're going to
multiple wells over and over again so we
have apoptosis you have some cell
proliferation
you have bacterial phagocytosis you have
cells migrating with variety of sensors
in them you have a multi color assay
going on over ten laps so these are all
possible images Microsystems
so at this point I want to introduce the
image Express nano system a
cost-effective automated imager for
every lab ideal for routine assays it's
available with 2 X 2 60 X objectives 5
filters
solid state light engine with a very
long expected lifetime and it comes with
2 options available transmitter light
and or environment control the product
has a large field of view just like
other image Express systems better than
25 nanometer X Y Z and Z stages high
image quality eat the new easy to learn
software automatic stitching and
montaging on-the-fly
image analysis and label-free transfer
the light analysis so the solar cell
report Express software is easy to use a
browser-based interface tablet Flint
friendly touch screen compatible noted
no database and access and share your
data anywhere anytime you can use to
acquire data analyzed remotely share and
then present your data to your
colleagues note I'd like to turn this
presentation over to Oksana's Franco was
going to tell you more about the
applications that are possible to do
with this the new image Express nano
system using selects cell report Express
software
Thank You Grisha for your introduction
let me start is a short introduction for
self-reported software in the home page
you can see the icons for acquisition
analysis data review manatorian or
configuration let's go to the
acquisition you may start from a
protocol template first you select the
instrument then go to the settings you
may select plate types different colors
or magnification then you can acquire
the image instrument will take images
and present it as a composite image you
can modify the exposure time or focus
offset for different stains
you can select or modifies the area of
your interest you can set up the
analysis on the fly to set up the
analysis go to the list of analysis
templates and select the one for example
cells : the analysis counts and analyzes
cell using intensities in different
colors then you can select the area for
analysis finally you can select the
wells to acquire you can save your
protocol and create the data file you
may check the settings before
acquisition and then hit the Run button
image analysis allow characterization of
cells and various markers you may start
from pre-selected analysis template or
create your own there are more than 20
predefined analysis protocols including
cell viability differentiation
mitochondria cell cycle and many other
applications here you can see the images
of cells stained with three dice nuclear
dye in blue follow it in in green for
cytoskeleton and meta tracker orange dye
for mitochondrion for the analysis you
can select from variety of available
protocols for example select
self-scoring analysis cells current
analysis is based on finding new clean
then scoring cells as positive or
negative for the appropriate marker
nuclear or cells defined by dimensions
minimum and maximum also by intensity
threshold over the background you may
start from the pre-selected numbers or
you can modify those by typing desired
values you may use automatic or manual
definition for example in the outer mode
you can just click to find the objects
no clear
you can use manual option to trace
desired objects for example cells
finally you can run test analysis and
see the mask of the objects and also the
measurements after analysis is done you
can select graphical presentation dot
plots heat maps paths or tables the next
part of our presentation is dedicated to
multi parametric essays for compound
screening and toxicity assessment the
latest trends in biology highlighted by
increase in complexity of essays it
includes complex cell models and
phenotypic multi parameter adults the
instruments have to enable increasing
complexity of essays and also ease of
use and throughput the flowchart was a
typical automated image an essay
includes cell plating treatments in this
compound staining then imogen images
analyzed by software and allowed to
derive multiple measurements that would
characterize the effect of compounds on
cell morphology
for example for multi-parameter set a
toxicity sa contain a M can be used for
defining the number of life cells also
cell morphology characterization nuclear
dye can be used to determine nuclear
intensity shape or apoptosis and might a
tracker Orange used to measure
mitochondria potential or October jail
cells can be imaged live after one
single step of die addition also you can
use fixed cells protocol to evaluate
additional markers in this case
cytoskeleton cell analysis quantifies
biological effects for multiple
measurements Multi parametric essays are
especially useful for description of
complex effects subtle changes and allow
to describe various phenotypic effects
for example you can observe very subtle
effects of compounds in this case
two-sport apoptotic cell by measuring
cell area with signal intensity you can
describe changes in cell spreadin and
also changes in cytoskeleton in this
case with paclitaxel you can spot
changes in a number of nuclei or nuclear
shape you can also measure cell
shrinking or cell detachment in this
case lists Paris barium
finally you can use multiple
measurements to define AC 50s for
different compound effects in
collaboration with cellular dynamics
company we developed proxy CT assays for
stem cell derived cell models
cardiotoxicity assays are extremely
important for drug safety evaluation and
neuronal toxicity assays can be used for
variety of applications including
disease modeling or testing chemicals
for the possible impact on neural
development we described in the past the
functional cardiac SI using calcium
fluxes this si can be done on several
electric devices instruments including
flipper plate readers and also imaging
instruments cell morphology evaluation
brings another level of important
information the developed methods for
either live cell or fixed cell toxicity
evaluation cell staining includes the
combination of several dice as we
described before here you can see the
images of control cardiomyocytes and
cells treated with stars Korean or
doxorubicin we tested the panel of known
cardio toxic compounds and tabulated
cardiac toxicity cells were treated for
24 hours readouts include nuclear count
and intensity also cell area and stain
intensity and also the numbers and
percentage of positive or negative cells
for cardio toxicity sa lifestyle
analysis or self scoring analysis was
used in a drop-down menu you can select
or add different measurements you may
select particular wells for review of
images you may see control wells also
wells treated with cardio toxic
compounds like amiodarone doxorubicin
star aspirin
also you may reviews the analysis masks
for control and other compounds
we defined AC fifties for cardiotoxic
effects using the number of positive
cells and the era of positive cells the
essay allowed the tech cardiotoxicity
and also around compounds for the effect
we have used stem cell derived neurons
for neurotoxicity essays there is an
increase in concern about the large
number of untested chemicals in the
environment and there is a pressing need
to develop reliable and efficient
screening tools to indentify chemicals
that could affect human health the a
valet Daphne Wright outgrows si as
possible screen to explore ability of
compounds to adversely affect the
developing nervous system neurons were
treated for 70 hours with various
compounds and effects on neurite
outgrowth were evaluated this is the
picture of isil neurons in a culture
stained with cutscene a.m. near a trace
in analysis allows to define cell bodies
narrator grows numbers of processes and
branching points here you can see the
screenshot of the entire plate for
neurotoxicity si knee right
tracing protocol was used for image
analysis in the data review mode you may
see the images or numbers different
readouts can be selected for the heat
map narrator gross number of branches or
others you can see those responses for
compound effects then if you go back to
the images you may review untreated
samples and samples treated with
compounds for example material mercury
analysis masks can be visualized for
outgrowths cell bodies and branches
then you may go to the graph
presentation for example narrate
outgrows versus branches you may
highlight those dots and then go back
and forth between the graphs images hit
maps and the table here you can see the
images and tracings of neurites
3d trees compounds known for their
neurotoxicity dose-dependent
disintegration of networks observed we
have created ic50 plots for multiple
readouts the ic50 is for multiple
measurements presented in the table
notably the IC 50s were different for
different readouts for example IC 54
branching were typically the lowest and
for cell viability significantly higher
than the outgrows branching or processes
so stem cell derived as a models in
combination with advanced imaging
methods can be a very efficient tool for
toxicity evaluation finally I would like
to describe several other essays that
can be used for variety of applications
one is cell count and characterization
in transmitted light the analysis can
segment and accurately count cells in
transmitted light that would allow to
monitor cell proliferation toxicity of
migration label-free without using any
dyes we demonstrated the accuracy of
analysis by comparison with nuclear
count using fluorescence as you can see
numbers were very close for different
cell concentrations also we were able to
measure toxicity effects measuring cell
numbers and area in transmitted light
you can also combine transmitted light
is fluorescence and run cells Koren
analysis that can be used for evaluation
of transfection efficiency and many
other applications DNA damage is another
important application for toxicity
assessment assistant damage to DNA is
frequently addressed with research
applications because of its implications
in diverse diseases including genetic
mutations cancer and aging DNA damage
may happen spontaneously or be a result
from exposure to ionizing radiation or
chemical compounds cellular DNA damage
can be visualized and 25 using
antibodies against phosphorylated h2ax
protein also the accused nuclear stain
Hearst 4 counters painting on the fly
cells : analysis efficiently identifies
nuclei with damaged DNA then cell
reporter Express software includes a
pre-configured cell scoring application
model that model can classify nuclear
for positive or negative for the marker
imaging was done miss 10x objective and
it was sufficient to calculate accurate
concentration response curves you can
see those responses for my demise scene
or pet herbicide out of a G is regulated
process of the gradient and recycling
damaged proteins and organelles in
response to cellular stress this
regulation of of Thapa G has been
established to play a role in various
narrow degenerative diseases and also
cancers for the assay development we
were using visit well neuroblastoma cell
line and it is very important to define
those small objects by imaging you can
see here out of a G particles stained
with site of ideal and also mitochondria
particles stained with my tracker orange
we measured the number area and
intensity of autophagy particles and
compared effects for several inducers of
out of a gym and finally count and
characterization of small particles
allows to measure gpcr activation by
agonist or antagonist in the entrance
floor si trance floor si uses cell lines
which are Express GPCR gene of interest
and also fluorescently tagged bat arrest
in the predefined pits and vesicles
analysis model can identify and count
pits and vesicles which form by better
arresting translocation we presented
here a new imaging system and software
that enable imaging and analysis of
complex biological responses in
automatic screen informant those complex
multi parametric measurements allow
better characterization of biology and
compound effects thank you so much for
your attention I'd like to thank you for
your time if you have additional
questions for the speakers are emails
given right there grow show chandi at
mold f calm and oksana Suren co at mold
of calm and if you want to learn more
about our products please visit us at
and now we would like to open it up to
questions from the audience please let
us know if there are is anything that
you would like more information about
information to us so before we start
with all of your questions here's a
quick reminder about how to reach us
today questions can be sent for you the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll get to as
many as we can and before I begin the
question and answer session I want to
advise with a series of poll questions
will appear on your screen during the
Q&A you may select your answers then
close the poll questions by clicking on
the X in the right corner karissa will
handle handle the Q&A and I will hand it
off to you Grisha
thank you very much Judy and thanks
Oksana I just give you a few seconds to
answer the poll questions that might be
popping up and then I'll just so to
these the questions that have come in
during the during the webinar and if you
have additional questions please submit
them and we will as she said we'll try
to get to them what Oksana like what
magnification is better to use for a
neurotoxicity versus Acharya toxicity a
say so in majority of my essays I use
10x standard 10x magnification which
allows to enable Phi through code
because with this magnification you need
to capture just and one image per well
in order to have a sufficient number of
cells but if you interested more in kind
of subcellular structures I would
recommend using 20x magnification for
neuronal cells and in some cases for
cardiac cells as well
there are a couple of questions about
transmitted light one both of them one
question is how well it works with
different cell types and the other one
is whether you can explain a little bit
about how how the soft identify cells
actively using the transmitter light so
the first question is about whether it
works good with different cell types in
fact the software has slightly different
application models which applicable for
different cell types so there is one
application model which is general use
and that one use can first go to this
majority of common cell types like we
evaluated it with the HeLa cells is cho
cells is cardiomyocytes
and for idiots pretty accurate cell
count and also area encounter evaluation
of covered area
so sometimes cells could be smaller and
for example blood cells or bigger like
pc-12 cells or some other cell types
like hepatocytes for those cell lines is
you better to use slightly different
application models which you kind of
called like light cells or deep count
those can be also used for rounded-up
non-adherent cells or for other cell
types so basically they recommend that
different so you start from general
application model and it's not satisfied
with results you can use different one
and pick which one works better for your
specific conditions it is very important
also for the transmitted light count to
have four focus right so that cells
appear crisp and very nice contrast so
that could be adjusted by
modification some acquisition parameter
like focusing or exposure time so and
also the second question was about
algorithm which segment I believe the
algorithm used the features of from
cells such as their brightness or
contrast or their size and we have
algorithms which based on an predefined
settings which can work for specific
cell types or specific cells
measurements and some other algorithms
they include machine learning components
which could be adjusted for your
specific cell types great thank your car
there's a couple of questions about the
type of samples we can put in the put
into the instrument one asks about
whether you can do slides and the other
asks whether you can do tissues and you
take onto those questions so the
analysis both acquisition and analysis
are suitable for the slide format so it
has a state in four slides where you can
capture entire slide and actually the
features of software where you can it
can be very flexible with this side or
kind of area you acquire so you actually
don't have a limitation which objects
you want to capture so which kind of
works very well for slides so first you
my ATM capture with greater
magnification and then zoom in and
capture your area of interest on a slide
and for analysis you can use the same
modules as for regular cells and it
would be kind of no difference in
handling this type of analysis
so different sites which would be
stitched together and analysis done as
such that you wouldn't see even seams
between different sites when Jim
acquires a sample at what day were the
neuro toxic compounds added for ice on
your own experiments yes this is
actually a good question so in my germ
in a published this type of essay
predators live where we used 48 hours
period between plating of knee Rights
and then addition of compounds in this
recent experiment
I added compounds 24 hours later and
then the culture was going to three days
and it's also possible to continue a
culture for more time like for five days
or seven days to evaluate not only
native activity but also near a
development component in this essay so
I'm just reading to the questions how do
you analyze the mitochondrial integrity
and what magnification you use for that
yes so for mitochondria evaluation
actually two different approaches could
be used so for really high throughput
mods where you would like to use like
10x magnification I would recommend to
use self-scoring analysis so which works
to identify intensity and area and score
cells for positive or negative in terms
of intact mitochondria potential and
there is also another approach could be
used which would deliver more
information about animal sensitivity for
mitochondria as say in this approach I
would recommend to use 20 X or 40 X
magnification
and actually count mitochondria granel's
and not only councils using good
granularity and application model but
also to define their intensities and
area for those granel's so that model
works very well for mitochondria
toxicity and also October GM
applications so but you just have to
keep in mind that if you use higher
magnification it is important to acquire
more than one site for a while so
usually we use like two or four sites if
you use 20x magnification or we
typically use for sites if we use for 2x
magnification that way you will get
sufficient statistical for to cover
cells and for viability variability in
cells cells there are thanks that song
again are the three for questions about
the calcium as they slide you through up
I'll answer one of them and then maybe
can pick talk a little what they assay
so the questions are what is the
acquisition rate for dynamic cardiac at
what what's the acquisition rate for
that assay how are the calcium imaging
data for neurons and cara mice has
analyzed and this is something like
would you do with full of flag stations
so the data that Oksana's showed for the
calcium was acquired with our image
express micro system most of the data
all the data in the system in this
presentation besides that was from a new
image success in nano so on the images
of micro systems you can acquire data at
a variety of frame rates all the way up
to hundred frames a second or even
faster but potentially possible if you
use a smaller area of the acquisition
window but maybe you can talk a little
bit about I think you probably some
paper
how you do the actual assay
so actually we published several papers
already on cardiac toxicity using
calcium flux methods most of this work
was done on a flipper so we have like
two paper in 2013 and some recent papers
as well in 2016 and kind of recently we
published paper on cardiac sarah waves
in sa drug development technology and in
that paper we actually described in
detail how you can do this essay using
imaging instruments so right now we have
four the algorithms which can analyze
the calcium fluxes the same way as it's
done on a flipper instrument so you can
define amplitude beatin rate also
distance between Peaks decrees and other
parameters so and there are kind of
protocols which described in the paper
from 2017 which you can use or you can
contact our technical support for more
information how to use this method so
what's important about speed of
acquisition so for calcium flux si if
especially if you use at least cells
from cellular dynamics international if
you typically use like eight frames per
minute aah 8 2 frames per second I'm
sorry and also you can even go slightly
lower than that like 3 frames per second
in an image express micro I typically
use like 10 frames per second for this
custom flex si butBut the systems are
capable of higher higher frame rate
acquisitions yes you can do up to higher
rates yeah if there's any other calcium
questions please go ahead and send them
in a question came about that I'll take
about the cell report Express and what
systems available on yes the cell
reporter express our new software is
available only on the image express nano
at this time
and our image success Microsystems our
continue to use our met Express software
and I don't see any additional questions
in coming in and so I'll give it a
couple of minutes otherwise I'll turn it
over to back to Judy to up fills out the
webinar you know a Grisha if you would
like we can allow you to say a few
things and while you are of questions
come in then when you're done you know
you could jump on to those questions
does that sound good
that sounds final sunny would like to
say something yes so I would like to use
this opportunity to acknowledge again
our past and present collaborators
especially cellular dynamics
international and also our collaborators
from institute of environmental health
so thank you I don't I just want to
thank people for coming and attending
our map advisors webinar and I hope to
see you again as I do at a future
webinar of ours and I would like to once
again thank Grisha Chandi and Oksana
Steranko for their presentation I would
also like to thank our sponsor molecular
devices for making it possible to bring
this presentation to you this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credit today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through May 2018
you'll receive an email from us alerting
you when it's available on-demand and
posted on lab routes calm you're welcome
to forward this announcement to any
colleagues who weren't able to join in
today thanks for logging on and
participating in today's broadcast we
will see you next time